- Welcome back y'all.
A couple weeks ago, the
very funny Ike Barinholtz
came by the show,
and if you didn't know,
he won Celebrity Jeopardy.
Like won the whole thing.
He's incredibly smart.
(audience cheering)
Well that got us talking
about what kind of student he was.
And as we do sometimes,
or just generally most of
the time here at the show,
we get a little carried away.
And so we talked for way too long.
But that means that you are in luck.
You're welcome.
Because today it is time
for another Kelly Extra.
So wait, were, were people you knew
from back home impressed
with your Jeopardy win?
I feel like I would've bragged about that
more than a Grammy.
(Kelly and Ike laughing)
- I would brag about a Grammy
more, but they're both great.
- [Kelly] I don't know.
- Well, my friends who knew me,
they kind of knew that
I was a trivia nerd.
But there was someone I knew who,
when I told them I was on Jeopardy,
they were like, "oh, you are
going to embarrass yourself."
(Kelly gasping)
- And now I stand outside their house
every morning with the trophy.
- Hold it?
- And they wake up, I'm
just standing there just-
- Like John Cusack, have
a playlist in your trophy.
- Just, just hold up the
trophy blasting Peter Gabriel.
(Kelly laughing)
- Sounds like a good morning.
- Kind of nice, nice way to wake up.
- Yeah. Did you ever, were you,
I feel like you're so funny.
Were you like a class clown?
Did you ever get in trouble in, in school?
- I did get in trouble.
I, I loved being the class clown.
The, the, the worst though was,
oh in like fourth or fifth grade,
I, I got in trouble and got
asked to leave the room.
And you know when
you're, you got the door,
but then you got the thin glass thing
so you can see into the room-
- Yeah.
- and they can see you?
Well, I thought it'd be
funny if I mooned them.
(audience laughing)
You know, mooning. It was
very popular in 1988, I guess.
- Yeah.
- And I mooned the class.
- I have mooned many a
people, I will tell you.
- It's, it's fun.
- It's funny.
- [Ike] It's like a fun thing
to do. - A bare ass is funny.
- A bare ass is funny.
- Yeah.
- If there's a mission
statement of this show-
- Or sad. Depending on the ass.
- Depending on the ass.
Depending on the ass.
- Yeah.
- At the time, mine was perfect though.
- Mine was in mint condition.
- Mine was absolutely perfect.
And I did it, my teacher,
when I turned back
to see the reaction, I
saw him looking at me
and I was like, oh boy.
And I came home and I
didn't tell my parents.
And the school called
and I didn't get to go to camp that year.
(audience awing)
Yeah, it's okay.
I, I go every year now though.
(audience laughing)
- Just to stick it to him.
Like, look at me now.
- Sleepaway camp for two
months out in the East Coast.
- No, that's huge though. Like-
- It was a big one.
- Yeah.
- It was a big one, but I
learned from my mistake and I-
- [Kelly] Keep your butt in your pants.
- I keep my butt in my pants now.
Where it belongs most of the time.
- Most of the time.
- Most of the time. Sometimes you gotta-
- Okay.
So are you at the point
where your friends,
'cause I have, you know, young kids,
and it's sometimes, I feel like,
your friends can kind of be the friends
of your kids' friends.
- Oh, exclusively, I think.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, you really-
- So play dates.
- Yeah, you get older and you say goodbye
to your friends.
And then you meet new
friends who have children
that your children like.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- But you have to sync it up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You can't have a situation
where your kid's like,
"I love Bobby."
And you're like, "yeah,
well his dad is a liar."
(Kelly laughing)
So you can't be friends with him.
- Sorry.
- So I do kind of, you know,
suggest to my kids like,
it's like, "oh, for your birthday,
who do you want to have, you
know, come over for dinner?"
And they'll be like, "oh, Sally."
I'll be like, "I don't know, I don't know,
I think she said she's out of town.
I know she's out of town
but you know who is not, Bobby is in town.
So why don't we have Bobby over?"
So I think it's good to kind of suggest
who your kids should be friends with
because it makes me a
little more comfortable.
- Yeah, 'cause it can
get, it can get awkward.